Sonne I'm just trying to help okay so
I'm trying to get out of the funk cut
I've been in in terms of just you know
every everything has been picking me off
lately and and I kind of want to
apologize for that
I can't guarantee it's going to change
because my reactions to stuff if stuff
comes out that takes me out I'm good
that's what's going to happen but um I
want to kind of think one of the
commenters on my last video about the
venom movie that's happening and that's
DBZ to zero zero two now he basically
said something that sort of set my the
wheel spinning in my head so here I'm
going off of that initial seat of
inspiration here are my suggestions to
Sony for five movies related to
spider-man that they could and in my
opinion should make before trying to do
a venom solo movie let's get right into
it
number one silk now still give a fairly
recent creation she's only been around
for a couple years and sort of the whole
idea with her was that the spider that
bit Peter and gave him all his powers
then kind of crawled away and before it
died it also bit somebody else that bit
another student by the name of Cindy
moon she got powers similar to but
slightly different from Peters and she
fights crime under the night the name of
silk so what you got basically right
there is just female Spider Man and as
far as standalone spin-offs code not a
horrible idea now this is one that it's
actually not impossible that we would
get although if it probably wouldn't be
sort of a standalone unconnected thing
the way it looks like the venom movie
that they're going to do and the reason
I say that is the character Cindy moon
somebody has been cast and is being
listed in the new spider-man homecoming
as Cindy moon now that does not mean
they are going to introduce silk it
could just be an easter egg for those
who are aware of her and you know her
actual identity but it does also see the
possibility that if they wanted to she's
already there will be up to lit my
number four choice spider-man you are
now this is spider-man looking dark
looking
I mean the title says it all spider-man
you are new are means black but also of
course film noir and sort of those old
sort of grizzled you know detective kind
of stories you know Humphrey Bogart the
Maltese Falcon kind of thing so you've
got spider-man in this really cool black
look in this sort of 1930 setting he's
fighting against Nazis he uses a gun
it's just a fundamentally different feel
to spider-man but it's still spider in
but it's just the change of that setting
when you move the character to a
different setting the character is going
to change because if he comes from a
different place is going to be a little
bit of a different person and spider-man
has been a surprisingly interesting and
enjoyable take on the thing from
something that could have just been like
a random of you know what if I complete
with one-off thing but now it's it's
yielded some some fun sort nothing of
any I think real meat or substance but
you know what it I think one of the
things that they could do if they're
really if they're going to just be
tossing out spider-man because let us
not forget that Sony animation is doing
a spider-man movie as well using Miles
Morales so they aren't opposed to having
multiple iterations of spider-man and I
say if you're going to do that let have
really different one spider-man noir is
a good way to go with that number third
pick black cat Felicia Hardy oh she's a
great character she's a lot of fun now
ideally I would prefer her to actually
show up in a spider-man movie proper
because her dynamic with spider-man is
really interesting as a potential love
interest because she has a thing for
spider-man she doesn't really care for
Peter and I've always found that to be
very interesting and fun and she's a
very fun character I mean she is very
much a very deliberately Marvel's answer
- Catwoman which of course is going to
make some people go oh the Catwoman
movie uh but I mean we can all agree
that with a horrible version of like the
antihero cat burglar you know a heroine
kind of thing so don't feel the need to
compare to that because that was a bad
version of that just because you make
another movie that has a character does
not mean it also must be bad I think you
can have her
you could have a really fun heist movie
ever get in over her head maybe with the
mob or maybe with some you know other
villains heck use it as a chance to
bring in one of the one of the big mob
bosses that isn't kingpin because
Marvel's using him but like somebody
likes Silvermane or tombstone have her
get on the wrong side of them were like
she's trying to you know pay off a debt
to those kinds of guys and it could be
like that that one last job and that I'm
out kind of movie but with a really
cool-looking character and they with
these claws and defend the silver and
the you know the white hair and I'd have
fun choice number two spider-gwen
hey why not first of all the look is
great I mean before I knew anything
about this character knew whether or not
she was any good I saw that look for the
first time I went that's a cool look I
like that a lot
and she is fun and interesting anyways
if you don't know who she is she comes
from an alternate dimension where Gwen
Stacy was bitten by the by the spider
instead of Peter Parker so instead of
becoming a martyr she becomes a
superhero and given how good and fun and
charismatic Emma Stone is I would almost
say it's worth going whole hog alternate
dimension bringing her back to play this
part I think I mean she was she was
great as Gwen she was one of the
highlights of the amazing spider-man
movies but if you didn't bring her back
again we get a little bit of that female
spider-man thing that we would have with
silk but there's something just about
that there's something triumphant about
a character whose identity in pop
culture is as a victim getting to be the
hero
and I think there's a nice metafile to
that which is the reason that I would
punch spider-gwen
over silk even though in some ways
they're a similar gimmick they were
female with spider-man's powers but
there's there's just something a little
a little bit extra about the baggage of
all the Gwen Stacy names I think is a
positive thing when doing spider Quinn
as a character and my top choice and
this is the one actually that DBZ 2 0 0
2 themselves brought up and it made me
go oh yeah and
I thought for a long time this would be
great idea and if Sony really wants to
commit to these alternate and
disconnected from the MCU things that
are related to spider-man just so they
can milk the heck out of this licensed
spider-man 2099 man come on this is one
I have a lot of affection for because it
came out right when I started getting
into comics and I was on the ground
floor I bought the first issue and I
mean I've got a lot of first issues from
the nineties because they were making a
lot of first issues of Lassa but a
little few I stuck with for a while and
it's good I love the characters nature I
love McGill O'Hara
I love the ways in which he's similar to
Peter in terms of being you know quippy
and and quick-witted and having a
scientific mind
Spyros like the way he differs he's
harsher he doesn't have the Uncle Ben
backstory so he doesn't have the same
weight of responsibility especially in
those early days and he doesn't value
human life quite to the same extent that
Peter does it makes for an interesting
contrast I also like the ways in which
is powerset differs yes he comes well
the rather than just is finger stick
he's got these little little claws that
jut out that are really dangerous I mean
it's like you've got tiny little whole
green claws on the tips of his fingers I
like the look I like the world
it's a blade runner-esque type world and
I always liked those kinds of setting
it's a little less it would be like
imagine the Blade Runner universe in the
daytime when it wasn't raining that's
kind of a feel of the 2099 world and
I've always enjoyed that setting I think
it's a lot of fun and I think Miguel
well here are the characters a lot of
fun and I think a lot of the villains
that they update I thought voltar 2099
was a lot of fun I thought his AI
assistant was a lot of fun then she's
just a lot that I love about that world
in that character and I think it will be
a really great way to purr it's only if
Sony's going to insist on milking this
property here's something that I think
makes a heck of a lot more sense as a
standalone disconnected from the MCU
then doing venom does so those are my
choices for five movies that Sony should
be making instead of venom but those are
my thoughts what about you are there any
alternate versions of spider-man or
spin-off characters from spider-man that
use the
could sustain their own movie outside
from venom because obviously that's
already happening whatever they are for
you or your thoughts on the ones I
already picked drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]